bienvenue dans ce cours sur la compréhension de l'information et du calcul quantiques, je m'appelle John Matus et je suis directeur technique de l'éducation chez IBM
Quantum. C'est la 12e leçon de la série et la dernière leçon de la troisième unité, qui porte sur la formulation générale
de l'information quantique. Cette leçon est centrée sur une notion fondamentale en information quantique, à savoir celle d'une
purification d'un état quantique. Une purification d'un état quantique représenté par une certaine matrice densité est un
état pur d'un système composé plus grand qui nous laisse avec l'état original lorsque le reste du système composé est
éliminé ou tracé. Chaque matrice densité possède une purification, et on peut apprendre beaucoup
sur les états quantiques et sur l'information quantique en général en étudiant les purifications. À un niveau intuitif,
les vecteurs d'état quantique qui représentent des états purs sont des objets mathématiques plus simples que les matrices densité, et en réfléchissant aux
purifications d'états, on est capable de voir des états quantiques arbitraires de systèmes comme étant simplement des parties de quelque chose de plus grand mais
plus simple. On parlera aussi de la fidélité entre deux états quantiques, qui est une valeur quantifiant leur
similarité ou chevauchement, et elle est souvent utilisée comme façon de mesurer à quel point un état particulier est bon par rapport à
un état idéal. En particulier, on discutera de la définition de la fidélité ainsi que de certaines de ses propriétés de base, et on verra
comment la fidélité se connecte aux purifications. Voici un aperçu de la leçon : on commencera par les purifications, notamment la
définition et une preuve simple de leur existence, qui nous indique comment en trouver une si on en a besoin. Ensuite on discutera de ce qu'on appelle
la décomposition de Schmidt d'un vecteur d'état quantique de deux systèmes, et on verra comment les décompositions de Schmidt sont liées aux
purifications. Puis on discutera d'une relation d'une importance capitale entre deux purifications quelconques du même état, connue sous le nom d'équivalence unitaire
des purifications. Et finalement, on passera en revue quelques exemples. On se tourne ensuite vers la fidélité,
sa définition et certaines de ses propriétés de base. On parlera du lemme de la mesure douce, qui est un
fait très pratique reliant la fidélité aux mesures. Et pour conclure la leçon, on se tournera vers le théorème d'Uhlmann qui
établit une connexion fondamentale entre la fidélité et les purifications. Commençons par la
définition d'une purification. Une purification d'un état qu'on suppose représenté par une matrice
densité est un état pur d'un système composé plus grand qui laisse l'état original avec lequel on a commencé lorsque le reste
du système composé est tracé. On peut exprimer cela plus précisément en termes mathématiques comme
suit : si on a un système X dans un certain état rho, ce qui signifie que rho est une matrice densité représentant un état de X,
et que S est un vecteur d'état quantique d'une paire de systèmes XY tel que tracer Y à partir de l'état pur C ket bra plus I
nous laisse avec rho, alors on dit que S est une purification de rho. Naturellement, les noms n'ont pas d'importance —
on peut nommer nos systèmes et nos états comme on veut, et l'ordre des systèmes n'a pas non plus d'importance. Par exemple,
si le système Y était à gauche plutôt qu'à droite mais que tout le reste était identique, on qualifierait quand même SAI de purification de rho. Mais on
restera principalement avec cette configuration pour le reste de la leçon, par souci de simplicité. Et la première chose à dire
concernant la définition est que les purifications existent toujours pour chaque matrice densité rho. Pour être plus précis, chaque matrice
densité rho possède une purification comme la définition le décrit, à condition que le système Y soit au moins aussi grand que X, c'est-à-dire
que Y ait au moins autant d'états classiques que X. La notion de purification et le
fait que les purifications existent toujours s'avèrent d'une importance capitale, et c'est aussi en partie ce qui rend l'information quantique belle — j'espère pouvoir
t'en convaincre à la fin de la leçon. Prouvons maintenant que chaque matrice densité possède une purification, et dans
le processus on verra comment mettre la main sur une purification lorsqu'on en a besoin. Comme dans la définition,
supposons que X est un système et que rho est une matrice densité représentant un état de
X. Considère maintenant n'importe quelle expression de rho comme combinaison convexe d'états purs, comme on l'a écrit à l'écran. En d'autres termes,
pour un certain choix d'entier positif n, on a un vecteur de probabilité p0 jusqu'à pN moins 1, ainsi que des
vecteurs d'état quantique phi0 jusqu'à phi N moins un, et en faisant la moyenne des états purs correspondants pondérés par les probabilités, on
obtient rho. Par exemple, on pourrait utiliser le théorème spectral pour obtenir une expression de rho comme celle-ci, et si on le faisait,
on pourrait prendre n comme étant le nombre d'états classiques de X. En fait, on pourrait prendre n comme étant le rang de rho, qui est
égal au nombre de valeurs propres non nulles de rho en comptant chacune un nombre de fois égal à sa multiplicité, et
c'est toujours inférieur ou égal au nombre d'états classiques de X, mais cela pourrait être plus petit. D'autre part, cela n'a pas
besoin d'être une décomposition spectrale de rho, et ces vecteurs d'état quantique n'ont pas besoin d'être orthogonaux. Par exemple, n'importe quelle expression de rho comme celle-ci
convient. Et voici une purification de rho : la somme s'étend sur les mêmes valeurs que
dans notre expression de rho, et dans la somme on prend les racines carrées des probabilités multipliées par phi A tensoriellement
avec ket A. Ici, on suppose que 0 jusqu'à n moins un sont des états classiques du second système Y, donc
il est logique que S soit un vecteur d'état quantique de la paire XY, comme dans la définition. Il n'est pas vraiment important
d'utiliser des états de base standard de Y dans cette expression — tu pourrais substituer n'importe quelle collection orthonormale
d'états à la place de ket 0 jusqu'à ket n moins un si tu le voulais. Et maintenant on peut vérifier que c'est bien
une purification en calculant la trace partielle sur Y. Voici une expression de l'état qu'on obtient en effectuant la trace partielle :
la trace de ket A bra B vaut soit un soit zéro selon que A est égal à B ou non, donc l'expression
se simplifie à notre expression originale de rho. C'est aussi simple que ça — il est donc très facile de mettre la main sur une
purification, du moment qu'on a suffisamment d'états classiques de Y, ou alternativement un ensemble orthonormal assez grand à utiliser à la
place des états de base standard ket 0 jusqu'à ket n moins un. Et au passage, si le nombre
d'états classiques de Y est inférieur au rang de rho, alors il n'y aura pas de purification — je te laisse
y réfléchir si tu le souhaites. Voici un exemple : considérons
la matrice densité que l'on a vue plusieurs fois dans la leçon sur les matrices densité. Ici on a une expression de cette
matrice densité comme combinaison convexe d'états purs — ce n'est pas une décomposition spectrale, mais on s'en
moque. Et sans presque aucun effort, on peut écrire une purification de l'état en suivant la
recette. Ce n'est pas la seule purification de cette matrice densité — les purifications ne sont pas uniques, mais ce n'est pas grave.
WEBVTT
La définition ne dit rien sur l'unicité, et en fait il existe une relation très intéressante entre les différentes purifications du même état, mais
on en discutera un peu plus loin dans la leçon. Ensuite, on va considérer les décompositions de Schmidt, qui sont des expressions
de vecteurs d'état quantique bipartites sous une certaine forme que je vais décrire dans un instant. Elles portent le nom d'Erhard
Schmidt, le même Schmidt connu pour la procédure d'orthogonalisation de Gram-Schmidt. Mais dans le cas des décompositions de Schmidt, elles ne devraient probablement pas
porter le nom de Schmidt — c'est en fait mathématiquement équivalent à quelque chose qu'on appelle la décomposition en valeurs singulières des matrices, qui est quelque chose qui a été
en fait redécouvert plusieurs fois, mais cela arrive parfois. Quoi qu'il en soit, voici ce qu'on entend
par décomposition de Schmidt : pour un choix arbitraire d'un vecteur d'état quantique S pour une paire de
systèmes XY, il est toujours possible d'écrire S sous une forme spéciale — cette forme est telle
qu'on l'a ici à l'écran, où R est un entier positif, p0 jusqu'à pR moins un sont des nombres réels positifs qui
ensemble forment un vecteur de probabilité, x0 jusqu'à xR moins un sont des vecteurs unitaires correspondant au système X, et y0
jusqu'à yR moins un sont des vecteurs unitaires correspondant au système Y. Cela ne semble peut-être pas particulièrement
spécial jusqu'à ce que je te dise que les deux ensembles x0 jusqu'à xR moins un et y0 jusqu'à yR moins un doivent être
orthonormaux. Alors pourquoi est-ce spécial ? Eh bien, si on devait choisir n'importe quelle base pour l'une des deux bases, disons
les vecteurs X qui correspondent au système X, on pourrait toujours exprimer S sous cette forme, et cela nous forcerait à
sélectionner les vecteurs Y d'une façon particulière. En fait, on le fait assez régulièrement, comme on le fait avec une base standard lorsqu'on
se prépare à analyser une mesure dans la base standard. Mais en général, même si on choisit une base orthonormale pour les
vecteurs X, les vecteurs Y qu'on obtient ne seront pas nécessairement orthonormaux. De même, si tu choisissais une
base orthonormale pour les vecteurs Y et que tu essayais d'exprimer S sous cette forme, tu pourrais le faire, mais les vecteurs X ne seraient pas
nécessairement orthonormaux. Et finalement, si tu choisissais des vecteurs orthonormaux pour les deux systèmes et que
tu essayais d'exprimer S sous une telle forme, cela ne marcherait pas nécessairement car tu pourrais avoir besoin de termes croisés. Or, il n'y a qu'un seul
indice dans cette somme, qui est a, donc la forme est spéciale. Mais il est toujours possible
d'écrire un vecteur unitaire S donné comme ça. Voici comment procéder : calcule d'abord une décomposition spectrale
pour l'état réduit de l'un ou l'autre des deux systèmes — peu importe lequel. Mais pour décrire comment s'y prendre, regardons l'état réduit de
X. On trace donc Y, ce qui signifie que p0 jusqu'à pR moins un sont les valeurs
propres de cet état réduit rho, et x0 jusqu'à xR moins un sont des vecteurs propres unitaires correspondant à ces valeurs propres. Et
par ailleurs, on ignore les termes pour lesquels les valeurs propres sont nulles, car ces termes ne contribuent rien à la
somme. C'est-à-dire que p0 jusqu'à pR moins un sont tous des nombres réels positifs, et R est le nombre de valeurs
propres non nulles en comptant les multiplicités, ce qui est égal au rang de rho. Cela nous donne p0 jusqu'à pR
moins un ainsi que x0 jusqu'à xR moins un. Il ne reste plus qu'à trouver les vecteurs y0 jusqu'à yR moins
un. Il n'y a qu'un seul choix possible — ces vecteurs sont uniquement déterminés à ce stade, et ils peuvent
facilement être trouvés à l'aide de la formule simple affichée à l'écran. Et ce qui est remarquable, c'est que
si on définit ces vecteurs de cette façon, ils sont garantis d'être orthonormaux, ce qui nous donne une décomposition de Schmidt. Je ne le démontrerai pas dans cette
vidéo, mais ce n'est pas trop difficile, et tu peux consulter le contenu écrit de la leçon si tu es intéressé — vérifie
la description de la vidéo pour un lien, comme d'habitude. Comme exemple, considérons ce
vecteur d'état quantique qu'on a obtenu comme purification de l'exemple de matrice densité sur lequel on revient sans cesse.
Ce n'est pas une décomposition de Schmidt car les états zéro et plus ne sont pas orthonormaux, mais on peut en trouver une
à l'aide de la procédure que je viens de décrire. La première étape consiste à calculer une décomposition spectrale pour l'état
réduit de X, qui est ce même exemple de matrice densité. Voici une décomposition spectrale de celui-ci, qu'on a vue dans
la leçon 9. On choisit donc p0, P1, x0 et X1 comme
indiqué à l'écran. p0 et P1 sont les valeurs propres de rho, et x0 et X1 sont
les vecteurs propres unitaires correspondants. Il reste donc à calculer y0 et y1. Si on le fait, on obtient ket plus
pour y0 et -1 fois ket moins pour y1. Ce n'est pas immédiat — il faut
effectivement faire le calcul pour le voir, mais c'est bien ce qu'on obtient. Comme prévu, ces deux vecteurs sont orthonormaux, comme
ils le seront toujours si tu as effectué les calculs correctement. Et ça nous donne une décomposition
de Schmidt. Les décompositions de Schmidt sont très pratiques dans de nombreuses situations, et on verra bientôt ce qu'elles nous disent
sur les purifications. Les purifications ne sont pas uniques : un état quantique donné représenté
par une matrice densité aura en fait infiniment de purifications. Il existe cependant une relation étroite
qui tient toujours entre deux purifications quelconques du même état, et elle est parfois appelée l'équivalence unitaire
des purifications. Voici comment ça marche : soit rho une matrice densité
représentant un état quantique d'un système X, et supposons qu'on ait deux purifications quelconques de cet état qui sont
des états purs du même système composé. Pour être concret, supposons que S et phi
sont des vecteurs d'état quantique d'une paire de systèmes XY qui tous deux nous donnent rho quand le système Y est tracé.
Ce que dit l'équivalence unitaire des purifications, c'est qu'il doit exister une opération unitaire U agissant uniquement sur
le système Y qui transforme S en phi. Autrement dit, bien que ce soient
des purifications arbitraires de rho et qu'on ne suppose rien à leur sujet sinon qu'elles purifient toutes deux rho et qu'elles sont
toutes deux des états du même système composé XY, elles doivent être équivalentes en un certain sens, à une opération unitaire sur Y
seul. On verra quelques exemples illustrant pourquoi c'est intéressant et quelles implications ça a, mais d'abord
voyons pourquoi c'est vrai. Partons d'une décomposition spectrale de rho, qui est la
matrice densité que S et phi purifient tous deux. Et tout comme on l'a fait en discutant de la décomposition de Schmidt, on
va supposer qu'on a écarté tous les termes correspondant à des valeurs propres nulles, de sorte que p0 jusqu'à pR moins un
sont tous des nombres réels positifs, x0 jusqu'à xR moins un sont des vecteurs propres orthonormaux de rho, et R est le
WEBVTT
rang de rho. Et juste pour mentionner en passant, remarque à quelle fréquence on fait appel au théorème spectral à ce stade —
c'est un outil incroyablement pratique, et on serait vraiment perdus sans lui. Maintenant qu'on a une décomposition
spectrale de rho, on peut calculer les décompositions de Schmidt de nos deux vecteurs, exactement comme avant. Et elles vont être
presque exactement identiques : les coefficients et les vecteurs X sont les mêmes, car ils proviennent de la décomposition spectrale de l'état réduit, qui
est la même pour les deux vecteurs. La seule différence, c'est qu'on peut obtenir des vecteurs différents pour le second système. Pour
le premier vecteur, qui est S, on obtiendra un ensemble de vecteurs y0 jusqu'à yR moins un. Et pour le second vecteur, qui est phi, on obtiendra
une collection éventuellement différente qu'on peut appeler z0 jusqu'à zR moins un. On a donc maintenant des décompositions de Schmidt
pour nos deux vecteurs, qui se ressemblent beaucoup, sauf que les vecteurs pour le second système peuvent être différents. Mais ce sont
des décompositions de Schmidt, donc ces deux collections sont toutes deux orthonormales, et on peut simplement choisir
une matrice unitaire U qui envoie ya sur za pour chaque a. On peut toujours faire ça : les opérations
unitaires sont en fait équivalentes aux applications linéaires qui transforment une base orthonormale en une autre. Et si
ces deux ensembles ne s'avèrent pas couvrir l'espace entier correspondant à Y, on peut toujours les étendre tous deux en des
bases orthonormales à l'aide de — par coïncidence — la procédure d'orthogonalisation de Gram-Schmidt. Et c'est ainsi que l'équivalence
unitaire des purifications est prouvée. Dans la leçon quatre de la série, on a discuté du protocole de codage superdense
qui permet à un émetteur de transmettre deux bits classiques à un récepteur en envoyant un qubit, au coût d'un ebit
d'intrication partagée. Je suppose donc que tu es déjà familier avec ce protocole. Et le but de cet exemple est de brièvement
expliquer comment il se connecte à l'équivalence unitaire des purifications. Rappelle-toi que la façon dont
fonctionne le protocole, c'est qu'Alice et Bob partagent un ebit, autrement dit un état de Bell phi plus. Alice choisit de transformer cet
état de Bell en l'un des quatre états de Bell selon les deux bits qu'elle veut envoyer. Puis elle envoie son
qubit à Bob, qui mesure pour voir quel état de Bell il a. Remarque que les quatre états de Bell
nous donnent tous le même état réduit pour le qubit de Bob, qui est l'état complètement mélangé. Et en fait, c'est déjà suffisant
pour conclure que le codage superdense est possible : les quatre états de Bell purifient l'état complètement mélangé. Donc, par l'équivalence unitaire
des purifications, on sait qu'il doit être possible pour Alice de transformer l'état de Bell phi plus en n'importe
lequel des autres en appliquant une opération unitaire à son qubit. Bien sûr, il n'est pas difficile de trouver des opérations unitaires qui
fonctionnent vraiment, et elles sont très simples. Mais c'est néanmoins intéressant qu'on puisse parvenir à la conclusion que c'est
possible sans même penser aux opérations unitaires elles-mêmes. De plus, on peut conclure
que des généralisations du codage superdense à des systèmes plus grands sont possibles, à condition d'avoir un moyen de généraliser les états de Bell à des systèmes plus grands
tels qu'ils donnent tous l'état complètement mélangé comme état réduit de Bob. Et il existe en fait différentes façons connues de
faire ça. Un autre contexte dans lequel l'équivalence unitaire des purifications a des implications est la cryptographie
quantique. Et l'une de ses implications les plus importantes est qu'elle exclut l'existence d'un protocole quantique inconditionnellement sûr pour une
primitive cryptographique connue sous le nom d'engagement de bit. Alors qu'est-ce que l'engagement de bit ? L'engagement de bit est un exemple
de primitive cryptographique, par laquelle on entend une tâche ou procédure de bas niveau qui fournit une fonctionnalité de base pouvant
ensuite être utilisée comme brique de base pour faire des choses plus intéressantes, comme créer des schémas de signature numérique ou construire
des protocoles à connaissance nulle. Par exemple, dans le cas de l'engagement de bit, la fonctionnalité de base est qu'un
joueur, Alice, peut s'engager sur une valeur binaire de son choix auprès d'un second joueur, Bob, mais son choix reste caché
jusqu'à ce qu'elle choisisse de le révéler. On exige deux propriétés spécifiques d'un protocole qui implémente l'engagement de
bit : il doit être contraignant, ce qui signifie qu'Alice ne peut pas changer d'avis une fois qu'elle s'est engagée sur un bit. Et il
doit être dissimulant, ce qui signifie que Bob ne peut pas déterminer le bit d'Alice jusqu'à ce qu'elle choisisse de le révéler.
Ce serait donc assez bien de pouvoir implémenter cette primitive en utilisant l'information quantique, car c'est une
primitive utile. Mais sans hypothèses supplémentaires, il s'avère qu'il est impossible de le faire parfaitement avec l'information quantique, ni même
de façon approchée. Et l'équivalence unitaire des purifications révèle que l'idée à un très haut niveau est
que si un protocole quantique pour l'engagement de bit existait, il y aurait nécessairement une version purifiée de ce protocole où on peut imaginer qu'
Alice a un système A, Bob a un système B, et après que l'engagement est fait mais avant qu'Alice révèle, la paire AB est dans
l'un de deux états purs, psi zéro ou psi un, selon le bit qu'Alice
choisit. Si le protocole est parfaitement dissimulant, alors il doit être que Bob ne peut pas faire la différence entre les
deux engagements, donc son état réduit doit être le même pour les deux possibilités. Cependant, cela implique, par
l'équivalence unitaire des purifications, qu'Alice peut transformer l'un en l'autre en appliquant une opération unitaire
à A seul. Donc le protocole a complètement échoué à être contraignant. Il y a des détails que j'ai passés sous silence,
mais l'essentiel est que l'équivalence unitaire des purifications nous dit que cette primitive n'est pas quelque chose
qu'on peut implémenter de façon fiable en utilisant l'information quantique sans hypothèses supplémentaires d'une
certaine sorte. Le dernier exemple d'implication de l'équivalence unitaire des purifications est un théorème connu sous le nom de
théorème de Hughston-Jozsa-Wootters, ou théorème HJW en abrégé. Commençons par l'énoncé
du théorème lui-même — voici une version légèrement simplifiée pour éviter certains aspects techniques et se concentrer sur les
idées principales. Supposons que X et Y sont des systèmes et que phi est un vecteur d'état quantique quelconque représentant un état pur de la paire
XY. Et maintenant supposons qu'on réfléchit à l'état réduit du système X seul et qu'on trouve n'importe quelle façon de
l'exprimer comme combinaison convexe d'états purs, comme c'est montré à l'écran.
Par exemple, le nombre N en majuscule dans cette expression — c'est-à-dire le nombre d'états purs sur lesquels on fait la moyenne — pourrait
être arbitrairement grand, éventuellement bien plus grand que la dimension de l'espace correspondant à X ou à Y d'ailleurs.
Et ce que le théorème nous dit, c'est qu'il doit exister une mesure sur le système Y ayant N résultats telle que
ce qui suit se produit quand le système Y est mesuré. Premièrement, chaque résultat de mesure
apparaît avec une probabilité exactement égale à la probabilité correspondante dans notre expression de l'état réduit de X comme
WEBVTT
combinaison convexe d'états purs. Et deuxièmement, conditionné à l'obtention d'un résultat de mesure particulier, l'
état de X devient l'état pur correspondant de la combinaison convexe. Alors pourquoi est-ce
intéressant ? Eh bien, cela signifie que pour n'importe quelle façon de penser à l'état réduit de X comme combinaison convexe
d'états purs, il existe une mesure de Y qui rend effectivement réelle cette façon de penser à l'état réduit de X.
Et ce qui est remarquable, c'est que c'est possible même quand l'état phi est choisi en premier et que la combinaison convexe
est choisie plus tard — du moment que c'est une expression de l'état réduit de X, il y aura une
mesure de Y qui fonctionne exactement ainsi. Voyons donc comment on peut prouver
cela. On commence par deux expressions différentes pour l'état réduit de X, qu'on appellera rho par commodité.
Ensuite on introduit un nouveau système Z dont les états classiques sont les résultats de mesure possibles, ou
de façon équivalente les indices dans notre combinaison convexe. Et maintenant on peut observer que les deux vecteurs d'état quantique suivants,
gamma 0 et gamma 1, qui sont tous deux des vecteurs d'état pour le système composé XYZ, sont
tous deux des purifications de rho. Et pour être clair, quand on pense à ces vecteurs comme étant des purifications de rho, on
considère les systèmes Y et Z ensemble comme un seul système composé qui est tracé pour laisser
rho. Le premier vecteur gamma 0 est essentiellement la même chose que l'état pur phi original, sauf qu'on
initialise le nouveau système Z à l'état zéro. Il est clair que si on trace Y et Z, on se retrouve avec rho. Donc gamma
0 est une purification de rho. Le second vecteur gamma 1 est en gros le vecteur qu'on obtient en purifiant
rho à partir de la combinaison convexe, comme je l'ai décrit plus tôt dans la leçon. Cette fois le système Y est
initialisé, et je suppose par simplicité que zéro est un état classique de Y, mais tu pourrais substituer n'importe quel
état de base standard ou en fait n'importe quel état pur de Y dans cette expression, et ça ne ferait aucune différence. Dans tous les cas, tracer Y et
Z nous laisse à nouveau avec rho. Donc la conclusion est que ce sont toutes deux des purifications de rho, et donc par
l'équivalence unitaire des purifications, il existe une opération unitaire U sur la paire YZ qui transforme gamma 0 en
gamma 1. Et c'est tout ce dont on a besoin pour trouver une description d'une mesure qui fait ce que le théorème
dit. Une façon simple de la décrire est avec un diagramme de circuit comme celui montré ici à l'écran. En d'autres termes, on part de l'
état phi, on introduit Z initialisé à l'état zéro, on effectue U, et ensuite on mesure le système du dessus, qui est Z, avec une
mesure dans la base standard. En pratique, cela transforme phi en gamma 1, et
simplement en regardant la description de gamma 1, on peut voir que ça fait ce que dit le théorème, à savoir qu'on obtient
chaque résultat a avec probabilité pA, et conditionné à l'obtention de a, le système X est laissé dans l'état sigma a.
Et pour être clair, la mesure elle-même dont le théorème implique l'existence est implémentée par
tout ce qui se trouve dans le rectangle en pointillés sur la figure. Et si tu veux savoir comment la
mesure peut être décrite comme une collection de matrices, en voici une expression. Je n'expliquerai pas cette partie, et ce n'est pas
vraiment important pour les besoins de l'exemple, mais c'est une expression des matrices de mesure au cas où tu serais
intéressé. On va ensuite discuter de la fidélité, qui est une mesure de la similarité de deux états quantiques, ou alternativement de leur
chevauchement. On commencera par la définition, qui peut sembler un peu mystérieuse au
premier abord, mais on va la décortiquer, et j'espère qu'à la fin de la discussion je t'aurai convaincu qu'il s'agit en fait d'une
fonction bien plus agréable qu'elle ne semble de prime abord. Et voici la
définition : la fidélité entre deux matrices densité rho et sigma est égale à la trace de la racine carrée de la
racine carrée de rho fois sigma fois la racine carrée de rho. On va en
parler — d'abord, essayons simplement de donner du sens à la définition elle-même. On a trois racines carrées, et
elles font toutes référence à la racine carrée d'une matrice semi-définie positive, qui, comme on en a discuté dans la leçon précédente, est
l'unique matrice semi-définie positive dont le carré nous donne la matrice dont on prend la racine carrée. Comme
rho est une matrice densité, elle doit être semi-définie positive, donc on peut en prendre la racine. Et si on réfléchit à la racine de rho fois
sigma fois la racine de rho un moment, on voit qu'elle est aussi semi-définie positive. En particulier on peut l'écrire comme
M† fois M avec M étant la racine carrée de sigma fois la racine carrée de rho. On peut donc en prendre la racine
carrée. En particulier, on peut calculer une décomposition spectrale de la racine de
rho fois sigma fois la racine de rho, et pour en prendre la racine carrée, on a juste besoin de prendre les racines carrées des valeurs
propres et laisser les vecteurs propres tranquilles. Et finalement on prend la trace de
cette matrice. Et comme la trace est égale à la somme des valeurs propres, on obtient l'expression qu'on a ici
même. Donc c'est probablement quelque chose que tu ne veux pas calculer à la main en général, et cette explication n'offre peut-être pas
beaucoup d'insight sur la fidélité ni sur pourquoi on s'y intéresse. Mais j'espère que ça clarifie le sens
technique de la formule. Au passage, parfois les gens définissent la fidélité comme étant
le carré de la fonction que j'ai définie ici, et ils appellent cette fonction la racine
de fidélité. Tu verras les deux définitions, ce qui peut certainement prêter à confusion, mais en général ça n'est pas le cas
car les gens prennent généralement soin de préciser quelle définition ils utilisent. Et tu devrais
faire de même. À mon avis, il n'y a pas vraiment de bonne ou de mauvaise définition. Je la définis
comme ça simplement parce que j'ai pris l'habitude de le faire ainsi, et je trouve que c'est un peu plus pratique — j'imagine parce que je préfère mettre au carré
quelque chose plutôt que d'en prendre la racine carrée plus tard si le besoin s'en fait sentir. Mais tu es bien sûr libre de faire ton propre
choix. Quoi qu'il en soit, revenons à la fidélité telle qu'elle est définie ici. Il existe d'autres façons équivalentes de
définir la fidélité, et c'est en fait une fonction assez remarquable à cet égard — elle peut en fait être caractérisée de façons assez intéressantes.
Voici une façon assez simple de réécrire la définition en termes de norme trace, qu'on a vue vers la
fin de la leçon précédente. Je ne suis pas entré dans trop de détails sur la norme trace, et en particulier
je ne l'ai même pas définie pour les matrices non hermitiennes. Mais elle a une définition assez simple — une façon de définir la norme trace d'une
WEBVTT
matrice arbitraire M est qu'il s'agit de la trace de la racine carrée de M fois M†, ou de façon équivalente de la trace de la racine
carrée de M† fois M — on obtient la même valeur dans les deux cas. Et on peut utiliser cette définition pour simplifier la
définition de la fidélité comme on l'a en bas de l'écran. C'est bien car ça révèle qu'elle est
symétrique dans les deux arguments. On peut aussi exprimer la norme trace d'une matrice carrée M comme le
maximum de la valeur absolue de la trace de M fois U, maximisé sur toutes les matrices unitaires U, ce qui n'est pas évident mais
est vrai. Et ça nous donne une autre expression pour la fidélité. On a donc ici trois
définitions équivalentes de la fidélité, et ce n'est que le début — il y a plusieurs autres définitions équivalentes, et
on en verra une particulièrement importante qui vient du théorème d'Uhlmann vers la fin de la leçon.
Bien, c'est sympa, mais que signifie tout ça à un niveau intuitif, et pourquoi devrait-on s'intéresser à cette
fonction ? Pour répondre à ces questions, il est utile de considérer le cas particulier où au moins une des deux matrices densité
représente un état pur. Si les deux états sont purs, alors la
fidélité est simplement la valeur absolue du produit intérieur entre les deux vecteurs d'état quantique. Et d'une certaine façon,
c'est la motivation principale pour la fidélité elle-même : la valeur absolue du produit intérieur entre deux vecteurs d'état quantique
est toujours un nombre entre zéro et un, et elle nous donne un moyen naturel de mesurer le chevauchement entre
deux vecteurs d'état quantique. Et tu peux penser à la fidélité comme une façon utile et bien comportée d'
étendre cette mesure du chevauchement des états purs aux matrices densité. Si l'un des états est pur
et l'autre n'est pas nécessairement pur, on a à nouveau une expression simple pour la fidélité, qui peut être assez
pratique, et cette expression est montrée ici. La fidélité possède de nombreuses propriétés intéressantes,
et c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles les gens l'utilisent. Elle a une définition qui n'est pas vraiment
très agréable, mais c'est une fonction très utile quand même, et elle est souvent très facile à utiliser en partie grâce à ses nombreuses
propriétés remarquables. Regardons donc quelques-unes d'entre elles, en commençant par l'observation que la fidélité entre deux matrices densité
est toujours un nombre entre 0 et un. Elle est zéro si et seulement si les états
sont orthogonaux, ce qui signifie que leurs images sont des sous-espaces orthogonaux, ou de façon équivalente que le produit des deux matrices est
zéro. Et la fidélité est un si et seulement si les deux matrices densité sont égales. Tous les autres cas sont quelque part entre
les deux, mais intuitivement, plus la fidélité est proche de un, plus les états sont similaires, ou alternativement
plus ils se chevauchent. La fidélité est aussi symétrique — je l'ai mentionné il y a quelques instants. C'est
assez clair à partir de l'expression qu'on a vue pour la fidélité en termes de norme trace, mais c'est une chose importante à reconnaître
néanmoins. Ensuite, la fidélité est multiplicative pour les états produits, ce qui signifie que la fidélité entre deux
états produits est toujours égale au produit des fidélités entre les états
individuels. Voici une propriété vraiment utile : si on a deux matrices densité quelconques de même taille,
ainsi qu'un canal qui prend ces matrices densité en entrée, la fidélité ne peut que devenir plus grande quand ce canal
est appliqué aux deux états. Autrement dit, en termes de fidélité, les canaux ne peuvent que rendre les états
plus similaires entre eux — ils ne peuvent pas les rendre moins similaires. Et finalement, pour cette liste du moins,
il existe une relation assez étroite entre la fidélité et la distance trace entre les états, qui est définie
comme la moitié de la norme trace de la différence entre les deux matrices densité. La distance trace entre deux
états est fortement liée à notre capacité à les distinguer, ce qu'on a discuté dans la leçon précédente dans le contexte de la
discrimination d'état et du théorème de Helstrom-Holevo. Tandis que la fidélité quantifie le chevauchement de deux états.
Donc même si ce n'est pas exactement la même chose, il n'est pas surprenant qu'il existe une relation entre ces
deux quantités. Quoi qu'il en soit, ces inégalités, généralement appelées les inégalités de Fuchs-van de Graaf, rendent
cette relation mathématiquement précise. Et il est assez important qu'il n'y ait absolument aucune dépendance ici sur la taille du système dont on parle.
On peut voir cette relation un peu plus clairement à l'aide d'une figure : si on a deux états et qu'on
place la distance trace entre eux sur l'axe des x et la fidélité sur l'axe des y, alors les lignes verticales
et horizontales correspondantes doivent se croiser quelque part dans cette région grise. La région la plus intéressante du
graphique, au moins en pratique, est le coin supérieur gauche de la région grise. En particulier, quand la
distance trace est très petite, la fidélité doit être très proche de un, et vice
versa. Ces inégalités sont utilisées très fréquemment, et l'une des raisons est qu'on se soucie souvent davantage
en fin de compte de la distance trace, car elle a une interprétation naturelle liée à la discrimination d'état quantique.
Mais la fidélité a tellement de propriétés remarquables qu'elle est en général celle qui est la plus facile à utiliser. Et tant qu'on est dans le coin supérieur gauche de
la région grise, ce qui est souvent le cas, on ne perd pas trop en convertissant entre la fidélité et la distance trace. Voilà donc
quelques-unes des propriétés de la fidélité — il y en a beaucoup d'autres, mais c'est un bon début, et j'espère que cette liste aide
à commencer à développer une intuition sur la fidélité. Voici un bel exemple de comment on peut
relier la fidélité aux mesures non destructives. C'est un fait très pratique connu sous le nom de lemme de la mesure
douce. Supposons qu'on ait un système X, un état de X représenté par une matrice densité rho, et une mesure sur le système X
décrite par une collection de matrices semi-définies positives. Supposons que l'un des résultats de mesure soit très susceptible
d'apparaître si on effectuait la mesure sur l'état rho. Par souci de simplicité, supposons
que c'est le résultat zéro qui est très probable, et en particulier supposons que ce résultat apparaît avec
une probabilité supérieure à 1 moins epsilon pour une petite valeur d'epsilon qu'on n'a pas besoin de spécifier. Epsilon
est juste un petit nombre réel positif. On a décrit notre mesure comme si c'était une mesure destructive,
mais on sait d'après la leçon précédente qu'on pourrait implémenter cette mesure de façon non destructive, et spécifiquement on pourrait le faire comme
on l'a vu dans notre discussion du théorème de Naimark. Et ça fonctionne ainsi : chaque résultat a apparaît avec
une probabilité égale à la trace de PA fois rho, et conditionné à l'obtention de ce résultat, l'état de X change en
WEBVTT
particulier. Dans le cas où on obtient le résultat probable zéro, l'état devient la racine carrée de p0 fois rho fois la racine carrée de p0,
normalisée de façon à obtenir une matrice densité. Et ce que nous dit le lemme de la mesure douce, c'est que dans ce cas,
c'est-à-dire qu'on obtient bien le résultat de mesure probable, l'état obtenu n'aura pas beaucoup changé par rapport à l'
état original. En particulier, le carré de la fidélité sera nécessairement supérieur à 1 moins
epsilon. C'est excellent car c'est totalement général — on n'a rien dit du tout sur la mesure ou
l'état, sinon que l'un des résultats est très probable. Le lemme peut donc être appliqué dans
de nombreux contextes différents où on voudrait vérifier quelque chose sur un état quantique sans trop le perturber. Voyons donc comment le prouver.
Et pour l'essentiel, c'est en fait une question assez simple de calculer la fidélité entre les états pré et post-mesure.
On peut faire ça en utilisant la définition originale. En temps normal, ça nous laisserait avec une formule compliquée, mais
ici on a de la chance car ce qui se trouve à l'intérieur de la racine carrée extérieure est en fait le carré d'une matrice qui
s'avère être semi-définie positive, ce qui rend le calcul de la racine carrée trivial. On peut maintenant utiliser la propriété
cyclique de la trace ainsi que la linéarité de la trace pour simplifier notre expression comme c'est montré à l'écran. Remarque au passage que ce sont
toutes des égalités — on n'a donc rien approximé à ce stade, on fait vraiment juste simplifier. Mais maintenant on a besoin d'une
inégalité, car on voudrait se débarrasser de cette racine carrée au numérateur, et on peut en effet le faire si on accepte une borne inférieure. Et si
tu t'intéresses aux détails de cette partie, tu peux obtenir l'inégalité assez facilement en considérant une décomposition spectrale de p
0. Les valeurs propres de p0 doivent être entre 0 et un — c'est toujours vrai pour les matrices qui décrivent
des mesures. Et une fois qu'on sait ça, l'inégalité suit assez directement du fait que prendre la racine carrée d'un
nombre entre 0 et un ne peut que le rendre plus grand. Une autre façon de le dire, c'est qu'élever au carré un nombre entre zéro et
un ne peut que le rendre plus petit. On peut maintenant simplifier encore un peu, et on obtient la racine
carrée de la trace de p0 fois rho. Finalement, en élevant les deux membres au carré et
en substituant notre borne sur la probabilité, on obtient ce qu'on voulait. Donc la formule pour la fidélité
n'est pas la plus agréable ou la plus facile à utiliser au monde, mais ici elle fonctionne en fait assez
bien. Pour conclure la leçon, on va examiner le théorème d'Uhlmann, qui est un fait fondamental sur la fidélité qui
la relie à la notion de purification. Ce que dit le théorème en termes simples, c'est que la fidélité entre deux états
quantiques quelconques est égale au produit intérieur maximum, en valeur absolue, entre deux purifications de ces
états. En un peu plus de détail : supposons que rho et sigma sont des matrices densité pour un certain système X, et que Y est un
système qui a au moins autant d'états classiques que X, ce qui nous garantit que ces deux états ont des purifications qui sont
des vecteurs d'état quantique de XY. On peut alors exprimer l'implication du théorème sous la forme de l'équation
montrée à l'écran : la fidélité entre rho et sigma est égale à la valeur absolue maximale du produit intérieur
entre phi et S, maximisé sur tous les phi et S qui purifient respectivement rho et sigma.
Reformulons cela proprement et travaillons avec l'énoncé mathématique précis. On va maintenant prouver
le théorème, mais d'abord ça vaut la peine de prendre un moment pour apprécier qu'il nous offre une façon plutôt intuitive de penser à la
fidélité. Il s'avère aussi être assez utile en lui-même, par exemple pour prouver des choses encore plus intéressantes sur
la fidélité. Pour le prouver, on va commencer par des décompositions spectrales de nos matrices
densité — sans surprise. Une fois qu'on a des décompositions spectrales, il est facile de trouver
deux purifications spécifiques de ces états. Mais ici, on va en fait utiliser une
astuce. Remarque que dans les deux cas, on n'a pas un vecteur de base standard comme second facteur tensoriel, contrairement à ce qu'on a fait plus tôt dans la
leçon. On a plutôt le même vecteur que dans le premier facteur tensoriel, sauf qu'il a une barre dessus, et
ça signifie le conjugué complexe entrée par entrée de ces vecteurs. En d'autres termes, on prend essentiellement juste une
seconde copie des vecteurs propres, mais on prend le conjugué complexe de chaque entrée. On verra pourquoi on fait ça dans quelques
instants, mais ce n'est pas du tout évident qu'on devrait faire ça — c'est pourquoi on appelle ça une
astuce. Quoi qu'il en soit, ce sont des purifications de rho et sigma respectivement, et c'est vrai en vertu
du fait que nos vecteurs propres sont orthonormaux, et donc leurs conjugués complexes entrée par entrée le sont aussi. Et maintenant on peut appliquer l'équivalence
unitaire des purifications, qui dit que chaque purification de nos deux états peut être obtenue en
appliquant une opération unitaire au système qui est tracé. Pour les purifications spécifiques qu'on
vient de choisir, les opérations unitaires n'ont pas besoin d'être les mêmes pour les deux purifications —
bien sûr. On utilise donc la lettre U pour la première et la lettre V pour la deuxième.
L'idée, c'est que chaque purification de nos deux états peut s'écrire comme on l'a à l'écran, pour
un certain choix d'opérations unitaires U et V. Et maintenant on peut prendre l'expression
du théorème et simplifier. Si on substitue nos expressions pour phi et S et qu'on simplifie un peu, on
obtient l'expression montrée ici à l'écran. Il y a quelques étapes là-dedans et je n'ai pas montré les détails —
tu sais quoi faire si tu veux le faire. Mais laisse-moi mentionner que la raison pour laquelle on a choisi les purifications comme on l'a fait
était de permettre à ce produit intérieur de se simplifier exactement de cette façon. En particulier, on a mis les conjugués complexes
là pour pouvoir en fait retourner les produits intérieurs dans le second facteur tensoriel afin d'obtenir la forme spécifique
qu'on a ici. On y est presque. On peut maintenant utiliser la propriété cyclique de la trace ainsi
que les décompositions spectrales avec lesquelles on a commencé pour obtenir cette expression. Et à ce stade, on peut
utiliser l'une des façons alternatives d'exprimer la fidélité à l'aide de la norme trace, et on
a terminé. Il y a certainement des détails que j'ai survolés très rapidement, et c'est le genre de preuve qu'il faut
vraiment travailler soi-même pour bien comprendre. Mais j'espère que ça te donne l'idée
de base. Et comme d'habitude, tu peux trouver plus de détails dans le contenu écrit de la leçon, dont le lien figure dans la description de la vidéo.
Et c'est la fin de la leçon, qui portait sur les purifications, la fidélité et les liens entre elles. Et c'est aussi
WEBVTT
la fin de l'unité, qui portait sur la formulation générale de l'information quantique. J'espère que tu te joindras à moi pour
la quatrième et dernière unité de la série, qui porte sur la correction d'erreurs quantiques. Merci de regarder.